nous sommes sur la rue jean-talon à
montréal
léo calderon et nous accueille avec son
père à la pâtisserie familiale sampietro
c'est quand même un magnifique de voir
que watson moi j'ai commencé ici les 5
ans à 12 ans je faisais la crème glacée
la patrie
depuis ce temps les eaux a appris à
faire les folies at elle vraiment
spécial compagnie c'est quand même un
classique comme les canaux lee hall
était la mise ou créée par les soeurs du
monastère de santa rosa de lima sur la
côte amalfitaine
elles deviennent à naples en 1818
les pâtisseries tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui les folies at elle bénéficie
maintenant de l'appellation produits
agro alimentaires traditionnels italiens
à ce qu'il ya à gaza va fêter une partie
qui qui fait comme elle n'a mis que
kilomères qui farcie avec la
traditionnelle s'est farci avec la
polenta et on commence par faire de la
pâte
il ya quatre ingrédients ya la farine
bien peu de miel
seul et de l'eau mais la chaussée qu'il
faut l'avoir bien dur vraiment dur plus
dure quasiment qu'une pâte alimentaire
le 13 à 6 livres
après ça on la passe dans le mouvement
en la rend demain ce puits la pâte sera
généreusement duit de graisses végétales
là il faut commencer à la rouler puis
c'est là que tu vas voir que le les
faîtages commence à se développer
[Musique]
une fois que le rouleau est fait en
attendant quatre heures
[Musique]
les heats
nico et on commence à aller travailler
fall il faut les et leur jeu comme un
chapeau comme un peu d'appuis vous voyez
chaque feuille charpente
c'est important d'apporter sept morceaux
de pâte là à la température de la pièce
parce que ça donne une certaine manière
de l'effacer si vous remarquez c'est
vraiment comme une coquille de mal ça
prend le temps que ça prend ce qu'on
peut tricher c'est une bonne soit elle
est vraiment minces
au point que c'est cela perçoit pas que
c'est de la porte si c'est dur ça veut
dire que la porte était pas assez mince
si je commence à dérouler son jeu peu ce
qui est arrivé à papineau est retourné
de trois fois tellement qui est mince
que des feuilles paix des feuilles puis
des feuilles que des feuilles voyez là
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment minces de
kompa c'est transparent quasiment ses
ouvrages ce travail je crois d'avoir vos
parents autour comme ça tous les jours
c'est ce que les grosses discussions des
familles spaus on a la chance de les
voir tous les jours nous sommes gâtés
d'avoir un parent proche de nous qui
nous a aidé encore nous c'est une grande
force pour farcir les folies hôtels
traditionnels
il faut préparer la police
on l'a fait avec de la semoule refus de
sucre des fruits confits de l'huile de
cassis et de la fleur d'oranger et
l'important cellule de cassis c'est ce
qui fait le goût vraiment particulier de
soi yater eu de cassé ça donne un petit
goût des lieux de cannelle c'est comme
les petits corps de saint valentin les
petits coeurs rouges fait que ça donne
un petit goût de main il existe une
variante que les oem bien préparé et qui
fait la joie des clients
si on ordonne à dès qu'on a on a inventé
le quidam ans en a fait à six avec la
pâte à choux la pâte à chou comme vous
savez ça fait une expansion dans focus a
fait que ça crée un vide
il reçoit vous pouvez l'effacer avec
n'importe quoi
costard de moitié crème légère et crème
fouettée pour en faire un dessert ou
encore avec une bande ricotta bon parce
que c'est l'heure de goûter
oui j'aime beaucoup le contrat de
texture croustillante tomber piraterie
sa série qatar
vraiment et la dernière et non la
moindre la traditionnelle j'ai appris
qu'il faut pour respirer dessus non
merci beaucoup
non chez vous j'attends une belle jamais
ou si si
[Musique]